ت صور اقمار اصطناعيه حصلت عليها الجزيره
تغيرا للتموضع الاسرائيلي في خان يونس في
ال 24 من ديسمبر كانون اول ويظهر او يظهر
اللون الازرق اماكن تموضع اليات قوات
الاحتلال في ال عش من ديسمبر بينما يظهر
اللون الاحمر تغير تموضعها في ال 2ش من
الشهر الجاري اما اللون الاصفر فاظهر
تجريف جديدا للمباني والاراضي واظهرت
الصور السابقه في 19 من ديسمبر كيف كان
تموضع الاليات شمال خان يونس بين شارعي
السكه وصلاح الدين وظهر تجريف في هذه
المنطقه من الشرق باتجاه الجنوب ما يشير
الى محاوله توغل جديده عبر ازاله المباني
وتجريف الاراضي
الزراعيه معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي سياده العقيد مرحبا بك كيف تقرا
هذه الصور التي اظهر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
لاعاده تموضع بعض القوات قوات الاحتلال في
قطاع
غزه نعم تحيه لك المشاهدي قناه الجزيره لا
شك بان هذه الصور تظهر تغير في طبيعه
التموضع بالنسبه لقوات الاحتلال وهذا ما
تمليه عليهم طبيعه الموقف وطبيعه الارض او
الاهداف المستقبليه بحيث تكون هناك مناطق
اجتماع اماميه لهذه القطاعات يمكن ان
تستخدمها هذه القطعات في فتره لاحقه
للتقدم الى مناطق يمكن ان تكون اهداف
محتمله لهذه القوات في الفتره القادمه
ولكن بشكل عام دعني اقول بانه الحرب في
المناطق المبنيه لا تتوقع منها نتائج
سريعه لذلك انا ارى بان هذه المرحله هي
مرحله حاسمه لكلا الطرفين وهناك عمليات
تنفذ من خلال اشرطه الفيديو التي نقلتها
قبل قليل تظهر عمليات مختلفه هذه العمليات
جزء من عندها جاء متحركا والقسم الاخر كان
في مواقع ثابته عباره عن كمائن ومصائد
للمغفلين واستخدام عبوات ناسفه وما الى
ذلك من اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه
وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن مرحله مرحله انهاك
ومرحله استنزاف وكسر شوكه القوات المتقدمه
في هذه المناطق بان تكون الخسائر كبيره
جدا وبنفس الوقت يحاول المدافع في هذه
الفتره ان يتجنب الخسائر بشكل كبير جدا
وان يحافظ على بناه التحتيه وقدراته العس
عريه للاستمرار في هذه المعركه خصوصا وان
هذه المعركه هي معركه متحركه وتتنقل من
مكان الى اخر حسب طبيعه القوات المتقدمه
وحسب حجم هذه القوات وحسب الاهداف التي
توكل اليها وبالتالي نرى بان الان يعني
جميع تقريبا محاور القتال تحتدم بشكل كبير
جدا سواء كانت في الشمال او في الوسط او
في الجنوب وبالتالي هو يحاول ان يحقق شيء
من الاهداف التي رسمت هذه العمليه
العسكريه ولكن يبدو بان هذه القضيه صعبه
جدا التحقيق خلال هذه الفتره لان المقاومه
لازالت قويه ولا زالت العمليات العسكريه
تنطلق عليه من من مناطق مختلفه حتى
المناطق التي تم الدخول اليها في الفتره
الماضيه بدات تعود فيها العمليات بشكل
كبير جدا وهذا يجعلنا نقول بان هذه
المعركه هي معركه نستطيع ان نقول حاسمه
ولن تكون فيها النتائج سريعه لكلا الطرفين
لتحديد الفت طبيعه الفتره المق او الاتجاه
الذي يصير فيه هذا الصراع سياده العقيد
حينما يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه قصف 200 هدف في
قطاع غزه برا وجوا وبحرا ماذا يمكن ان
يكون قد تبقى في بنك اهداف القوات
الاسرائيليه او الجيش الاسرائيلي لكي يقصف
بعد كل هذا الدمار الذي رايناه على مدى
العمليه العسكريه التي اقتربت من اتمام
الشهرين
نعم حقيقه للاجابه على هذه القضيه ارجع
الى التقرير الذي نوهت فيه قبل قليل الى
احدى الدبابات التي استخدمت قذيفه لضرب
مقاتل من كتائب القسام او من فصائل
المقاومه وهذا اشكال كبير جدا في هذه
القطعات لانك يجب ان تستخدم السلاح
المناسب للهدف المناسب يعني لا يمكن ان
تستخدم قذيفه لقتل شخص واحد هذه القضيه
فيها اشكال كبير جدا في مساله الاقتصاد هم
بالامس كانوا يتكلمون بانه مساله الاقتصاد
قد تكون ثرت في مساله الخسائر ولكن اليك
ان تتصور بانه يستخدم هذه القذيفه بالوقت
الذي جميع الدبابات تقريبا مزوده برشاش
متوسطه تستخدم لمقاومه الطائرات وتستخدم
لتوجيه البطانه او لتوجيه الرامي الى هدف
معين فيتم استخدام راقب اطلاقه المذنبه
لتحديد الهدف المطلوب قصفه ولكن عندما
تقصف يقصف شخص واحد بقذيفه دبابه اذا هناك
اشكال حقيقي في توظيف القدرات العسكريه
لهذا الجيش واستخدامها بشكل صحيح علما
باننا نتكلم عن امكانيات وقدرات كبيره جدا
يممكن ان تستخدم يعني قبل مده من الزمن
كانوا يتكلمون عن شخص موجود في بنايه
يطلبون من طائره مسيره ان تاتي لقصف هذا
الشخص وهذا ايضا اشكال اخر لماذا لا تقوم
القوات المتقدمه في هذه المنطقه بمعالجه
هذا الهدف لماذا تاتي هذه الطياره ولكن هم
يريدون تدمير اكبر ما يمكن من البذا فعلا
لماذا يستخدم الجندي الموجود داخل الدبابه
قذيفه للدبابه قد تكون يعني فعالياتها
اكبر بكثير من مجرد استهداف شخص او مقاتل
من الجهه الاخرى ولماذا تستخدم طائره
مسيره بدلا من اقتحام المبنى المتحصن في
هذا المقاتل لماذا يصنعون
هذا نعم هذه الاشكاليه الحقيقيه لدى
المقاتل في الجيش الصهيوني الذي يعاني من
رعب وخوف كبير جدا هذا الخوف يجعله ان
يستخدم اقصى ما لديه من قوه تدميريه لغرض
التخلص من هذا الخوف لذلك لا يبادرون الى
مثل هذه الاعمال لان القتال في المناطق
المبنيه نحن قلنا سابقا بانه القتال من
مكان الى اخر ومن شارع الى اخر ومن بنايه
الى اخرى هذا القتال يكون بهذا الاسلوب لا
تستخدم فيه القوه بهذا الاسلوب التدميري
لكي يتم الدخول الى هذه المدينه الان هم
يستخدمون سياسه الارض المحروقه للسيطره
على المدينه وهذه القضيه يعني شيكل اشكال
كبير جدا في مساله الاقتصاد بالقوه
الاقتصاد بالجهد يضاف الى ذلك بانه هدر
للامكانيات والقدرات يضاف الى هذا يعطي
دلاله واضحه على تدني القدره القتاليه
للجندي الصهيوني في في هذه المعركه يضاف
الى هذا بانه مع هذا نرى بان القدرات
الدفاعيه نرى بان الاستخدام حقيقي
للامكانيات والكفاءات وهناك توظيف ل
للاسلحه الموجوده لدى المقاومه بطريقه
يعني نستطيع ان نقول جيده جدا في هذه
المعركه والدليل على هذا باننا نرى بان كل
شيء يتم استخدامه حسب السياقات
وحسب الاساليب المعمول بها في القتال في
المناطق المبنيه وحسب التكتيك فهنا يتم
نصب عبوى ناسفه وهنا يتم نصب كمين وهنا
يتم استخدام الهاون وهنا يتم استخدام
القناصه حسب طبيعه الهدف وحجم الهدف
والسلاح المطلوب لتنفيذ الواجب هذا لن
نجده في الكيان الصيه نجد بان ما تستخدمه
الان القوى العسكريه هي القوى الغاشمه
لتدمير اكبر ما يمكن من اهداف موجوده
امامها حتى ولو كانت اهداف بشريه ثم
التقدم الى هذه الاهداف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي كان معنا من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا
لك